hey Jamie is next in Pitt Pennsylvania
hi Jamie how are you good Dave how are
you better than I deserve what's up okay
so um I am married in 3 years in a
blended family we just purchased a house
in July everything is in my husband's
name and he's not complying to budgeting
we've done the class we've done
everything and I've been supporting our
family on $2,800 a month a family of six
total um so I don't really know what to
do to protect myself and my family if
things don't work out with this house
and everything being in his name even
though I pay all the bills and mortgage
and so yeah I don't know he doesn't work
he dies on but because of child support
he bring Tom about $220 a week and then
I bring home about a thousand dollars
every two weeks okay and why is it he
doesn't want to work with you on the
budget I have no idea I'm like a big
girl why should I ask and then he just
said like I don't I don't I don't know
like we do counseling we did the class
we were on three B and then when we
bought this fixer-upper
um I comply to taking out a $10,000 401k
loan so I don't you know what baby step
on line and I don't know if I can help
you all because I mean you're not doing
anything I teach and you know better I
know no you didn't you went along with a
401k loan at ten thousand dollars you
went bought a house she couldn't afford
well at the time we could um well he
wasn't getting as much out he wasn't
getting the child support out and then
we decided to take him for the child
support you're not out of that are you
well not now now we have $10,000 for O&K
loan and did you hear anything out
talked about about getting into debt
again yeah well I have money and savings
um I'm more cash flowing the renovation
and though you are you borrow $10,000 on
your 401k you're not cash flowing
anything you're not doing you're not
doing what I teach you to do Jamie and
you know I can't help you it's what you
know we laid out a real simple plan you
went through Financial Peace University
and it's so simple it says don't borrow
money anymore but what's going on in
your house is is this guy does whatever
the crap he wants to do and you go along
with it and you called me and want me to
fix that I can't fix that you guys have
a marriage that's screwed up and you
guys need to be sitting with your pastor
with a good marriage counselor where you
decide what page you're going to get on
because he's going in one direction
you'd like to go in the other but you
keep complying and going along with
stupid stuff that he wants to do and yet
he won't even join you in the budget
discussion this is a messed up situation
kiddo this is the Dave Ramsey show hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show